We've covered a few new topics
in Android such as making custom
preferences with custom attributes,
using support library annotations, and
using shared preference listeners.
Most importantly we've now covered
the primary air estates for
the interaction points for our app.
It's important to take a moment here
to remember what we've done and
to talk about how to generalize
this process to work on whatever
app you may be refining.
First, we identified what interaction
points existed in our app,
each of which is a place where
errors and bugs can creep in.
Then we looked at what we already
done well at each of these points and
what air cases we had
not covered already.
This gives us a list of issues to
cover to avoid bugs in our app.
In a real app, we would also want to
take user feedback into account when
coming up with a list of
changes to spend resources on.
Finally, we went through
each of the issues and
designed a solution to
the problem at hand.
Some of these solutions were simple and
straight forward.
Some of them were more complex and
required prioritization but by covering
these issues, we've made our app
far more comprehensible when
errors inevitably occur.